no but that was like the thing I was
like I'm gonna flick the other day I was
like man I wanna watch a horror movie
it's October like I wanna watch a horror
movie every day if I can and then I was
looking around and I was like there's
only like 50 movies like on all these
categories like I need a place where I
can really spread my legs and explore it
ahh
spread your legs
Oh
hey guys i'm ryan right i'm jerry so
today we're gonna check out the scariest
video ghost video ever but ghosts attack
in malaysia but since this is a ghost
video i wanted to talk about a special
streaming service that we heard about
called shudder OHSU DD er yes Colin
Geddes he was the programmer for tiff
was literally first firm in MN yes and
he was a curator for this new streaming
service and what it is it's an online
streaming service of horror movies a
library of tons of different horror
movies separated by genre there are like
collections based on certain themed
monster category there's all kinds of
different categories so that way you
could find your favorite horror movies
in those categories which is really
helpful especially during Halloween time
and there's gonna be like exclusive
festival releases there's gonna be
original series they offer on there too
they have a free 14-day trial and it's
you know it's pretty 400 $4.99 a month
for seemingly probably unlimited horror
movies after a while it's cheaper than
Netflix they're always adding stuff oh
yeah and especially during Halloween I
mean what do you get to lose exactly and
you know like horror is a very you know
fan passion John Ritter so to have a
streaming service more like you know
somebody who clearly knows what they're
doing and sort of hearing and not just
kind of throwing whatever up there you
know is pretty rad I got a lot of
friends gentleman on this I gotta
subscribe
yeah I do that right now those films
clips sizzles and programmed just for
the shudder website so it's basically a
one stop shop for horror movies or
anything you can put your eyeballs on
man if you're into horror this is the
thing to be a part of basically is what
we're trying to tell you oh yeah if
you're not into horror get in horror
because this is it this is it this is
Halloween
so get pumped and get shut ur eyes yeah
I get get shuddered so there's a link in
the description box check it out if you
want to go and get some insight into
shudder and check out some horror movies
yeah please do
anyway let's check out the scariest
ghost video ever
because detect on a video in Malaysia
hotel is it just a hotel in Malaysia's
of the name
scare Jerry it's like watching a
paternal line - hey
Oh
oh my god she's flipping out I'd be
flipping at it yeah I would be losing my
[ __ ] right she'll cast out she's in
shock
who
get out of there woman that goes clean
up like perrolli or no
as the footage slow slow god that's
horrifying
would be that will be horrified
while
so I call
from a viewer perspective your life that
wasn't so bad but if you're in that
position yeah I would be the most
terrified [ __ ] thing in the world man
to be in that position whether it's a
real haunting or if it's just a prank
that still be terrifying
no obvious time prayers and shut up
prank if that's what it was anyway guys
thanks for tuning into the Chanel if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects and become
a reject or today yeah or a Ryan ah
Souris or uh or uh Righteous Kill
no no no the horrible phone and I get
cheer beared up on reasons to Jerry this
is true yeah we're getting uh we're
getting some youtube lingo going on here
yeah naming our fans yeah it's pretty
students V on t-shirts